Good morning, John. It's Wednesday.
No... yes... yes Wednesday, March 14th (yawn).
If it looks like I'm cold and tired it's
because I'm cold and tired.
Oh... I got up early this morning so i could
prepare for a phone call. I have two very
important meetings today. I had one very
important meeting yesterday. This is the
most very important meetings I've ever
had in a two-day period. My very
important meeting today starts in three
minutes and it is with Yahoo. There are
like a search engine and they have email
and some Newser... I don't know. I can't
tell you what they're calling about
because it's confidential. It's officially
time for me to call into that Yahoo
number and get started at my meeting. I have
finished the Yahoo call. So I started up
the Yahoo call by mentioning that I
had done some research on the people who
I was having a call with and I didn't
say: "Oh, I looked you up on the Internet"
to the people at Yahoo. No. I said:
"I googled you". Ugh. People at Yahoo don't google. People
at Yahoo would rather you not google.
People at Yahoo yahoo and I don't yahoo.
Other than that the meeting went very well.
John, I've been thinking about
nerdfighters and I've been thinking that
there should be a way to become a
nerdfighter. Possibly a series of tasks.
I think the first one of these tasks is to
figure out what kind of nerdfighter you
are. The second task would be to write a lyric of the nerdfighter song from the
perspective of that nerdfighter
character". I think I might be a magic the
gathering nerd. Do you know what Magic the
Gathering is? When i was in high school
it was definitely one of the nerdiest
things you could do and I was extra
nerdy about it because I was really bad
but I kept playing. The idea that you
have cards and they're kind of
collectible. They rank from really common
cards to really rare cards but there are
rules about the cards like you can't
play certain card unless you have other
cards out and then you can attack using
your card
against the other person's cards and
your cards have ratings for defense and
attack power. It's really very complicated.
When I say complicated
I mean nerdy. Ok, I think I figured out my
nerdfighter song. My collectible card
games are underrated, complicated and sophisticated.
If you think that my powers could be
defeated just meet my Shivan dragon and you're burninated
Nerdfighter, cards have power.
I'm a wizard of the coast and I rarely
shower.
Hoo, ha, ha.
Nerdfighters, I'll see you tomorrow.
Do you want to be a nerdfighter, too? Click
on the sidebar Brotherhood2.com where
it says nerdfighters and tell us what kind of
nerdfighter you are and put in your
nerdfighter lyrics.